to the submission topic so a part of
this interview that went viral of this
woman
was her talking about how she does
can I say this on YouTube I think I can
okay I'm just gonna hope she does anal
even though she doesn't like it because
he wants it
so
um the internet had a lot to say about
this part and I want to give you guys
some of the reactions from people when
they saw this so if you could pull up
the next
um
videos and I'll show them on my phone my
men love the idea of a submissive woman
submissive per its definition is ready
to conform to The Authority or will of
others
the prefix sub means under think of
subpar
submarine in short your world is under
his now there seems to be a theme Here
good girls versus Bad Girls a lock that
can be opened with many keys is a broken
lock and if you can't submit to a man
you're gonna die alone to my question
cement is
do you want Perfect Polly a puppet a
prisoner or a partner who has no problem
overtly challenging you King treatment
and knowing your partner's Love
Languages that's one thing being
submissive is a whole nother thing it's
its own thing if you find yourself
abandoning your wants needs desires to
make something work
I'm here to tell you
it was never a match to begin with all
the things that submission is
submission is not
doing sexual acts just to please your
man like
I get wanting to try something that
you've never done before to see if you
like it but once you've established that
you don't like it
and he knows that
what kind of guy still wants to do it
what's attractive about doing something
with somebody that doesn't want to do it
that's not submission that's abuse so I
want to get your initial reaction so we
have Brittany Runner who's saying that
you're basically uh
did it sound like borderline a slave to
you guys survey yeah under and then we
have the other girl who's talking about
how it's borderline abuse what what do
you guys think starting with you
so if you agree to it it can't be abuse
because you've agreed to it regardless
um
I think that depending on your
relationship and your Dynamic it should
be something that
quite political to be honest because
some people they need those things in
their life being in submission to a man
is not abused in my opinion just because
in your relationship the dynamic allows
that to take place a man's position in
your relationship allows you to be
submissive
um also as a woman
it to reciprocate the man's position
submission is part of that and there's
nothing wrong with it for me what
bothers me is there's a problem with
saying it like what is wrong with being
submissive
there's a time and a place to be
submissive and I think because it's in a
public Arena it becomes a nitpicky
process and I it's like why is this even
a discussion it's very personal quite
private
um in regards to the young lady saying I
saw the clip about the anal thing and
for me it was the lack of understanding
of basic biology that got me with her
and just because of that I switched off
so I just was like yeah it's for whoever
what do you think I'll say originally to
Brittany Renner or whatever her name was
she would have went from two extremes
really she said that you don't want a
perfect poly and then she also said on
top of that someone who overtly
challenges you which are too extremities
I was like what we don't want either one
of those anyway so the fact of the
matter is a woman can be submissive a
man can be the leader he can consult
with his lady about a subject and by the
end of the day he and she know that he's
got the final say so he would take on
people's evidence and information to
make him help make a better decision so
in that case I like what you said I'm
going to add that to my thoughts and I'm
going to make the decision and she's
happy with the fact that he's used her
information as well so it's not the
extremity of Perfect Polly or overtly we
sort of confronted or whatever she said
and then in terms of like the anal and
all that some people like that I'm not
really down with that but I don't have
anything against anyone doing what they
want to do but in a sexual sort of
Engagement with your partner you have to
be willing to try and satisfy them right
I mean you learn to grow together and
synergistically as I say I like that
word because when two people come
together they have that sort of blending
of energies and understanding of each
other and the better that is the better
the Sexes some people might be here or
like this and I like that but I could
never see it as some form of abuse
imagine if a girl doesn't want to give
you head wraps he's like I don't give
head or whatever other term you want to
use for that sexual act and then like
you want it and she's saying it's abuse
because she has to do it she doesn't
have to do it number one so it can't be
abuse but like would it be a form of um
like withholding from the man anyway and
in that case they can have negative
effects on your relationship so I think
they have to come to some sort of
agreement sexually some sort of balance
Synergy between the two people and it's
an old form of abuse if you've accepted
and got down with the deed anyway
realizes that
she made some being submissive seem as
if that the woman had to completely
dislike everything in order to please
her man and that's what made it
submissive I feel like there's that Mis
like understanding of a woman needs to
give up so much that she desires and she
wants in order to submit to her man no
to submit to your man or vice versa is
just to want to put this love and energy
in to please your your partner that
doesn't mean it has to take from your
own cup and I think that's a big
misunderstanding that we have nowadays
and when it comes to the second clip I
just I agree with everything you said
and I feel like that just nipped it in
the bud for me
okay for me for the first video I think
the lady kind of confused the word
submissive as actually meaning slave and
the two are not the same it doesn't
they're not the same you know I mean
being submissive especially in a in a as
a quality in a woman is something you
want to do it's nobody can come and drag
you to them and say you've got to do
this and you've got to do that women if
they're in a position where they like
their man they're comfortable with him
they will literally give themselves to a
person and that's not something you have
to ask for that's something that's
innate it's part of a an effeminate
quality of a woman's quality because you
know I mean she's met the masculine that
is appealing to her feminine nature and
it the two just complement each other
naturally and
I think she's looking at the meaning of
the word too much it doesn't necessarily
mean I mean she was deconstructing it
trying to talk about what the the prefix
is and the rest of the word and I'm like
you're you're doing a bit too much do
you know I mean actually understand what
the word means as it as as what it means
to be a woman rather than what it means
to be with property or owned you're not
property
but you are as a woman you do have that
inner quality that men like so just do
it have you ever noticed that the girls
always have a Horror Story whenever men
have a standard or whenever